قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
تركيا ماضيه في طريقها لانشاء منطقه عازله
على طول الحدود مع سوريا اضافر اردوغان
خلال مؤتمر صحفيين في انقره ان تركيا تعرف
الاسباب التي جعلت ما وصفها بالمنظمات
الارهابيه تعاود الهجوم عليها وان بلاده
تعمل على تدمير الارهاب في منابعه على حد
وصفه
الامن الجديده التي نطبقها بحزم تقوم على
القضاء على تهديدات المنظمات الارهابيه في
منابعها وهوما الدال اضعاف المنظمه
الارهابيه والتقليل من تاثيرها لحد بعيد
نحن مدركون للاسباب التي جعلت منظمه
الارهابيه تحاول رفع وتيره هجماتها في
الفتره الاخيره رغم الاضرار الثقيله التي
اصيبت بها وان شاء الله سنخرب هذه الخطه
الخبيثه والمشعه من خلال الانتهاء من
تاسيس الخط الامني على طول حدودنا